freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich freue mich richtig gas
darauf ist wird ultra lustig ihr habt
den titel gelesen aber es wird auch
ultra lecker und falls ihr euch fragt
wie wird das lecker markt bekommst die
schlechtesten rezept im internet in die
komische rezept im internet die antwort
lauten helau fresh und zuvor ihr euch
jetzt den sap standard youtube werbung
im spiel zuvor nachts nicht denn alles
ist diesmal anders ich selbst
abgeschrieben
bitte lasst uns zusammen arbeiten ich
liebe das nämlich ich will nicht zu sehr
ins detail gehen gewährt ist aber eines
der köstlichen gerichten die die mir
zugeschickt haben zubereitet als erstes
starten wir aber mit einem schlechten
rezept ich habe schon mal so ein video
gemacht ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
vielleicht sogar erinnern auch damals
schon merklich das internet nach den
schlechtesten rezepten durchforstet mit
der hilfe von loxstedt kopf ich bin
immer noch ein bisschen traumatisiert
das jetzt schon was zwei jahre her ich
habe damals nicht mal koch videos
gemacht aber heute mache ich kaufte
videos und heute starten wir auch schon
mit der ersten sache ihr seht es jetzt
hier eingeblendet ist es leider kein
scherz staat hawaii mit bratwurst staat
hawaii was könnte das sein ist hier ein
bisschen wie toast hawaii wir brauchen
eine packung fertigen pizzateig acht
kreise bratwürste sechs scheiben ananas
1 schalotte und currypulver jährige die
zutaten vor uns hitzer teig ananas
bratwurst ich weiß wirklich nicht was
ich sagen soll heute ich mache das nur
für euch ich hab euch das klar den
pizzateig ausrollen und in 10 x 5 cm
große stücke schneiden ich mache einfach
nur eine portion ich hoffe ihr versteht
warum schneidet jetzt daraus ein stück
gehen wir auch keine mühe das einfach
mit einer schwere meine leute ich mache
sogar oder wisst ihr was vielleicht ist
es ja lecker wir machen mal zwei
portionen brauchen wir wurden
ein brettchen aller das in würfel doch
die sogar ein bisschen luft aber ich
weiß ja nicht wie das ganze in
kombination mit bratwurst und pizzateig
aussehen soll
pizza hawaii ist ja schon so eine sache
die so die gemüter spaltet aber tat
hawaii ist glaube ich noch mal eine ganz
andere liga sämtliche vorbereitete die
genau das ist der grund weshalb ich
helmut resch liebe ich meine ich habe
jetzt schon ein bisschen erfahrung beim
kauf ich mache meine videos und sorgt
aber es gibt im internet genau solche
rezepte und wie soll man wenn man
anfängt entscheiden was gut ist und was
nicht genau diese aufgabe übernimmt herr
doch recht für euch unter anderem ich
sehe gerade hier steht die charlotte
waschen und fein hacken
was soll ich mit scham verarbeiten oder
was man steht guido die machen wir jetzt
auch noch teil ist dann haben wir es
aber auch geschafft kann es gar nicht
abwarten dieses geschmackserlebnis
auszutesten wer weiß vielleicht ist das
auch eine idee dass hörer probieren
solche gerichte zu nehmen und irgendwie
ein bisschen ferenczy zu machen das wäre
vielleicht was für video in der zukunft
aber erst mal bereitet mir das ganze
heute einfach 5 zu das muss man dem
rezept lassen ist es sehr einfach
vorbereitet aber dass sie doch einfach
nur noch traurig aus oder wir haben
charlotte und anderen das braucht und
jetzt kommt die brach los dazu so was
natürlich auch nicht fehlen darf sind
die beauty shot
[Musik]
es zeigt nicht beleidigen das wort
potiche verwendet zu haben aber ich gebe
das jetzt einfach in den backofen rein
erwarten wir 20 minuten und dann
probiert und das hier wirklich sagen
einfach übrig zu haben kenne ich schon
gar nicht mehr seitdem ich erschöpft
das klingt alles so scheiße wörtlich
aber ich meine es todernst jede zutat
von hello verspricht kommt bald
aufgebraucht du kriegst eine einzelne
knoblauchzehe wenn du eine einzelne
knoblauchzehe braucht ist also möglich
lebensmittelverschwendung geht gar nicht
mehr
wir kommen noch dazu wie gesagt das ist
ja immer wieder doch sprechen kommt und
wer jetzt hier auf unsere köstliche
taten habe ich ein bisschen bisschen
durst bekommen ich habe letztes von
sowas leckeren gehört heißt das kind auf
diesen leckeren schoko milch cocktail
oder naja das hier ist black und wir
lesen könnt kling täglich ist aber sehr
lecker von letzterem werde ich mich
selbst überzeugen müssen was ist
blackout sieht ja sehr erstmal nicht
rüber appetitlich aus wir gucken uns
hier zutaten an milch und cola und cola
und cola ich muss fairerweise sagen ich
glaube das ist das schnellste rezept was
ich jemals gemacht habe habe ich darauf
hat auch einen grund das ist das erste
und bisher einzige mal ist dass ich von
einem gericht und milch und butter
verarbeitet sind gehört habe es riecht
jetzt nicht super eklig zubereitungen
einfach mädchen cola zusammenmixen auch
eiswürfel servieren sorry das könnte
auch so ein baileys oder sowas sein
irgendwas was ein bisschen lecker ist
vielleicht sogar probiert lag kaum
[Musik]
alles was nur annähernd sprudel hat wo
milch dabei ist ist einfach teil steckt
körper wehrt sich dagegen mein körper
sagt mir trinkt das nicht die
vorstellung dass jemand der dieses
rezept erstellt hat 25 litern blackout
ring und irgendwie doch auch so an
sondern keine ahnung wochenende sich so
oft aufs sofa setzt uns nicht für unser
team ist so geil
warum warum nicht einfach cacau bauen
nicht einfach cola alles ist besser als
das lag aber keine gute idee meinen
körper wehrt sich dagegen wirklich
märchenspiel mein körper sagt nein aber
werde jetzt darauf warten dass das hier
fertig wird würde ich sagen
3 - eine kleine vorspeise vor die
werften mit einer chips platte für das
partner gefehlt ich weiß nicht ob ich
das hier auf den fotos seht das sind
chips das fleisch salat und oliven
zutaten 20 oliven 20 bis 250 gramm salat
in kann man fleisch flach hat leute hier
sind unsere zutaten wir haben chips
warum belässt man es nicht einfach dabei
sind auch lecker oliven fleischsalat
haben ihren weg machen wird würde ja
auch nicht erst natürlich ganz ehrlich
aber alles einzel ich doch gut soll
ordnung kann man mögen warum macht man
daraus eine chipkarte
wir nehmen es einen chat daraufhin
gleich salat garnieren das ganze mit
andere liebe
[Musik]
ich bin auch schlimmste gespannt wie die
unpraktisch das allein ist das macht
einfach die ganze zeit es kann auch
niemandem gegangen hier ist einer
unserer spezialchips ich muss
fairerweise sagen es ist weniger schlimm
als gedacht aber es ist auch meilenweit
davon entfernt gut zu sein ich war es
für den gesamten mund häufig so sehr so
genannten geschmäckern mario olive
gewürzgurke darin und dazu passt du so
auf diesen chatrooms
warum dazu noch ein black kaum wirklich
also wertlos unsere tat dabei fertigt
back gucken wir einfach mal die hälfte
box behaltet einfach mal kurz im
hinterkopf dass wir gerade so gekauft
haben und hier meine hall of fresh box
haben wir zum beispiel eine winterliche
grünen kursschub von unterfangen zur
auswahl halloumi aufstocker paprika soße
das ist das restaurant essen das kriegt
man in guten restaurants diese
komposition pfanne mit extra in
kokosmilch sauce mit zitronengras ingwer
wie geil ist das ich bin wirklich voll
und ganz überzeugt davon und das beste
ihr könnt das so ultra günstig probieren
und zwar habe ich mir telefonisch
gesprochen wenn wir dieses video machen
und wenn ich euch ein bisschen vorstelle
dann meine zuschauer auch was davon
haben können und ihr könnt mit dem kot
helau macht 50 25 euro auf die erste box
damit ist versteht so eine box das ist
wirklich schwer es ist viel essen das
sind 6 portion jedes gericht von denen
ihr kommt mit zwei portionen wirklich
von vorne bis hinten alles perfekt
durchdacht ökologisch frische zutaten
perfekte rezepte jeder griff das hin
kostet eigentlich 40 euro aber mit
meinem coach kriegt ihr 25 euro auf die
erste box das heißt die zeit für sechs
mahlzeiten die natürlich
tassen qualität 15 euro ich finde das so
heftig also wirklich bin sehr happy dass
ihr euch das anbieten kann und ich
glaube nach diesen ganzen live-schalten
sonstwas gehe ich tatsächlich auch
halloumi aufstocker paprika dazu
kunstkurs das hier ist jetzt auch werte
aber ich mache erst mal das leckere
essen und dann problem für das also dann
man kann jedes mal aus einer vielzahl
von gerichten auswählen nicht nur diese
drei wenn man 30 40 da nicht genau aber
es ist definitiv regieren was dabei die
nummer 27
und dann kriegen wir dieses paket hilft
manchmal auch und kurz darauf zwei super
frische spitz paprika petersilie 1
tomate zu gewürzmischung gemüsebrühe
eine handvoll cashewkerne warten egal
ist das bitte normalerweise wenn man so
was kochen kauft man sich im feld import
cashewkerne und dann hat man nichts
damit zu tun
150 gramm couscous das wird alles
aufgebaut wo sieben welcher mensch ist
einfach so rosin außerdem so einen
geilen rezept niemand deshalb nimmt man
nur 20 grad
dann gibt es noch dieses kleine ding
hier ich bin cool und nachhaltig das
hier ist eine gefriert tasche ein
kühlbeutel 96% und es passiert hier rote
frische und qualität über papier liest
man wird das einfach kopiert sondern wir
machen auf und ich kann also sagen würde
das ist hier drinnen eiskalt als einfach
ist diese mit meinem inhalt eine
pflanzen profit mache ich kein problem
wir gucken weiteren hier ist auch unser
halloumi nämlich drin und außerdem so
joghurt also hier ist alles was wir
brauchen perfekt funktioniert ich war
kein einziges mal vor der tür und das
hier auf meinem tisch sein und wir
kommen jetzt so sieht das ganze aus wenn
es fertig ist ultra lecker oder also
wirklich heftig hier sind alle zutaten
habe ich auch gerade schon aufgezählt
alles am start und hier ist unsere
zubereitung sechs schritte halloumi in
circa 1 cm dicke scheiben meinen part
halbieren in bösel streifen schneiden
welcher der petersilie hacken
cashewkerne also zunächst hallo ich
finde vision weiterer vorteil davon ist
halloumi ist jetzt auch nichts was ich
mir kaufen wieder wenn ich so eine
gestresste woche ab da bist du halt
endlich bereit
groß was auszuprobieren sondern du
geholt hat was was du kennst und dann
ist das heißt sondern sowie wie immer
quasi aber jetzt esse ich hatte hallo
niko kapanen petersilie ich freue mich
immer wenn ich nach einem stressigen tag
so trotzdem an den kühlschrank gehen und
dann habe ich da einfach ein geiles
gerichten ist eigentlich komme ich ja
auch sehr entspannen das einzige feld
beim kochen abhaken kann ist das
recherchieren das einkaufen das
saubermachen danach jetzt ist es unsere
cashewkerne teil
ich finde unsere paprika die schneiden
wir es in einen halben zentimeter dicke
scheiben jedoch dass butt da braucht
jetzt eine auflaufform geben wir unsere
tomaten zu paprika 1
sodann von mengen wir das ganze leute es
liegt jetzt schon so gut krise froh dass
richtiges zu essen und jetzt verteilen
wir darauf die hatten wie scheiße jetzt
steht nur noch die gewürzmischung drüber
und fertig das ding kann in den ofen für
20 minuten bei 220 grad
weil leute man kann natürlich den
bioläden zwischendurch hatte einfach in
die packung haben sie ist natürlich auch
aus papieren und ist damit einfach in
den raum der klassiker leute die kamera
ist mal wieder aufgefallen ich habe mich
am flughafen einfach in den ofen getan
davon noch die gemüsebrühe über gestreut
dann habe ich den couscous ihr die
schlüssel gegeben kommen das war
verbrauch geschüttet mit gemüsebrühe
verrückt waren 30 sekunden arbeit aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist das gericht jetzt
fast herzlich ich bin auf meine sachen
schuldig die tat habe
gucken wir uns mal an
[Musik]
also dann machen wir es kurz und
schmerzlos schalotten ananas leicht
angeschmorte drahtlos ein sehr knurriger
boden
deshalb was soll ich sagen
das passt nicht gut zusammen es sieht
nicht gut aus es ist nicht eklig soviel
wo sich dem rezept ihn aber das auge
isst mit
das auge vergisst so was auch nicht ich
werde von alpha man umso mehr freut sich
auf jeden fall jetzt auf meine chefs
luca fahne
wir gehen jetzt die hälfte von der
petersilie zum couscous die andere
hälfte sparen wir uns noch für die
schufa auch dann geben wir unsere
rosinen dazu und unsere cashewkerne denn
die schweizer fahne raus solange leute
das habe ich mir wirklich verdient ich
hoffe dass wieder durch bisher spaß
gemacht ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt auf
den test der herr loonie ist gar nicht
so schrecklich das kennen also wenig
arbeiten das so geil frisches exotisches
gesunde rezepte halloumi ist wirklich
sehr sehr gut habe schon genug gute
worte über eine flash verloren es ist
einfach sehr sehr komfortabel 850 oder
einer der links unten der video
beschreibung und spart bis zu 50 euro
eurer bestellung nächstes körper das
video war lustig und euch selbst einen
volltreffer